we've gone through these slides okay
right you have one word equality freedom
heart innovation entertain believe
i wanted to share this one slide these
are from
my morning session
and one person wrote nice t-shirt can i
have one too
i'm working on it right now these are
just for me a line is coming
and that was super inspiring now i
believe
so
the importance of having the one word
and then applying it to your social
media campaign
it does two things
one it makes your decision making
process easier
so we had a young woman stand up and say
her one word is empathy
now everything that she writes about is
going to be about empathy
if she ends up hiring
a graphic designer it has to be somebody
who believes in empathy
it makes the decision making so much
easier
but the other thing it does
is
it helps people talk about you
if you give people one word to help you
spread the message they're gonna
remember it and they're gonna do it
there's a guy who came up to me after my
first session said i'm in the travel
agency business
and uh wow that's like that's a brutal
business right everybody's selling the
exact same stuff there's no difference
in the product
and he said his one word is experience
he likes to give people an experience
when they go traveling
he wants them to have an experience
now this is something i can relate to i
hate going on beachy vacations
you know i come here i want to go to the
caves i want to do the rving i want to i
want to have an experience and right
away
he's now separated himself from every
other travel agent
and it's easy for me to talk about him
here it's easy for me to tell my friends
about him because he's given me the tool
to do it so when you find your one word
it makes it easier for you to make
decisions it makes it easier for you to
plan your social media campaigns
but it also makes it easier for people
to spread your message
people are hashtagging believe all over
the place
i make it easy for them
and you need to do the same thing with
your business